if somebody asks you what the volume was
of these different shapes could you give
them an answer off the top of your head
probably not maybe for the cylinder
because that's just the base times the
height you know the base is PI R squared
just the area of a circle times by the
height but how about a cone or a pyramid
or a sphere you could go and look it up
in a book but you could also derive it
for yourself and that's what I'm gonna
be showing you in this video in this
video I'm gonna show you how you can use
calculus to derive the volumes of these
shapes yourself I'm going to use the
cone as an example but you can apply the
same procedure to the other shapes too
okay let's get started so here's the
procedure we're going to approximate the
volume of our cone using a whole load of
disks these are basically cylinders and
we already know how to calculate the
volume of a cylinder because it's a
simpler shape it's basically the base
times the height so we're going to call
the height of each one of these
cylinders Delta H and we know what the
base is because it's got the radius R
and the base area is basically PI R
squared so if you can work out the
volume of this and then this and this
and this and add them all together
that's an approximation to the volume of
a cone now where calculus comes in is we
actually shrink this Delta H down to be
infinitely small which will mean that
we've got infinitely many of these discs
and when you hit those infinities that's
when your approximation becomes exact
and then you can actually prove what the
volume of the cone is so good thing to
do at the beginning is just to try and
get a bit of an intuition a bit of a
guess as to what this volume of this
cone is going to be we can start off
with the volume of this enclosing
cylinder so I'm going to set just some
constant so say it's got a height of big
H and the base has got a radius of big R
then the volume of the
in closing cylinder is going to be
volume equals PI R squared times H so we
know that the volume of this cone is
going to be smaller than the volume of
the cylinder because it's inside it and
it's going to be smaller by some factor
in the actual volume of a cone I'm going
to give you now is a third oops third PI
R squared H so this is what we're aiming
for this is the expression we're going
to derive hopefully with a slightly less
weird-looking three so here are the
three steps that we're going to do first
set up a sum second express the sum in
terms of the height and three do the
integration okay so step one setting up
the sum so we need an expression which
is basically going to be this disc plus
this disc plus this disc plus this disc
so what we can write is that the overall
volume is approximately equal to let's
just start on this first disc here so it
will be PI squared times Delta H so for
the first one and we're going to just
write the sum so we're going to use this
Sigma which is just the denotes we're
adding up a load of discs together so to
actually perform the integration later
we're going to have to represent this R
the radius in terms of height because
the thing we're integrating over is the
height we can't integrate over the
radius with respect to height you'll see
what I mean later but basically we need
to just rewrite this R and replace it
with some expression containing an H the
height so just to show you what I mean
in a drawing let's just draw out a
sideways view of this cone so here's
going to be my zero point we've got the
radius R so this R is a variable so it
goes from zero outs to here so so
basically it's related to the height the
variable that's height because when
you're at half the height
you have half the radius right so say
this disc here it's a half the height up
the cone and so it's got half the radius
here so there's definitely a
relationship between this H and this R
which we want to try and work out so
we've got a constant which is the base
of this has got radius R so the biggest
that the variable R ever gets is bigger
and H goes from 0 up to big H
that's the highest and it goes we've
just arbitrarily chosen that this is
going to be a zero zero point but this
is mathematics we can choose to do
whatever we want but this is just how
I've set it up to begin with so now my
challenge to you is to work out what is
the relationship between this little R
and this little H there's a bit of a
hint if you're 25% of the way up the
height you'll actually 75% of the way up
the radius if you have the way out the
height you're only 50% of the way up the
radius and if you're 75 percent of the
height you'll be 25% of the way along
the radius so because this is a straight
line there's a sort of inverse
relationship so my challenge to you is
to find the expression that relates our
to H here compose the video now if you'd
like to give it a go so this can be a
bit difficult this is kind of like an
abstract kind of problem solving part of
this whole integration you can't just
follow a formula this is something you
have to actually like play around with
yourself so the way I thought about this
is as follows if I imagine that the
radius is just just a 1 unit and the
height is 1 unit it keeps it simple so
if I am 25% of the way along this radius
to say I'm here and at this point here
if I've got our little R over big R that
means that if this is of like not 0.25
and this is 1 that means that no pointer
5 divided by 1 will give me no point 2 5
and so the height we want to be not
point 7 5 so we can take the same ratio
of heights
but we've got basically we need to start
from up here and minus 25 that's
so we've got big H minus little H over
big H so this is actually an expression
that gives us the formula for this line
here we can rearrange that in terms of R
so we can write it as R equals Big H
bigger - bigger over big H times H so
now what we could do is replace this
this R here with this whole expression
the trouble is this gets incredibly
messy because if we had this whole thing
squared
we'd have to multiply out the brackets
and it would be a big nightmare you
would actually end up with the right
answer but you'll end up doing a whole
load of algebra so there's actually a
way of expressing this thing here in a
much more natural way which gives us a
much more simple formula I just did this
as an exercise to show the pitfalls you
can fall into so what I'm going to do is
actually flip this on its head so now
this is our zero point this is our
radius variable this is our height
variable and now this line is basically
increasing for R and H at the same rate
so we can write little R over big R is
equal to little a - of pH because
there's a one-to-one correspondence here
when they're 25% 25% 50% 50% and 100%
hundredths so rearranging this now we
get R equals bigger over big H
age so now this is a lot more of a
simpler expression to substitute into
here so let's finish off step two now
expressing this volume in terms of the
height so I'm going to go up here so the
volume is approximately equal to the sum
of Pi and now we need to do the squared
so we're going to take this expression
here and square it so it will be R
squared over H squared times little H
squared times Delta H now we can just
simplify this a little bit more by
taking out constants which are PI big R
which is just the radius of the base and
big H which is just the height of this
cone so V is approximately equal to pie
bigger squared big H squared H squared
times don't age ok so now we're ready to
do step three which is to do the
integration so we can turn this into an
integral so now instead of having these
Delta H's this is where we shrink down
these sides to be infinitesimally small
we have infinitely many of them so right
now as I've drawn it here there's four
trunks so I could write this sum you
sometimes you can put a number at the
top of the bottom so it goes from 0 up
to 4 now what we're going to do is 0 up
to infinity and this is going to be
instead of a Delta H which has got a
finite size it's going to be infinitely
small basically what we do is we rewrite
that as an integral because that's
basically 1 integral is so the way I do
this is V is now equal to all this stuff
at the beginning PI R squared over
squared and now instead of a sum I've
got an integral going from zero so the
bottom here up to H big age and we still
got the H squared in the middle and then
instead of Delta H when I going to write
D H if you don't already know how to
integrate H squared I'm just going to do
it it's beyond the scope of this problem
to show you how to do that integration
but it's something that you pick up
basically you just raise the power up
one and then you have to divide it by a
factor corresponding to that power
you're raising it to so basically it
looks like this V equals PI R squared
over H squared and then this is what
I've done the integration use square
brackets so it'll be H cubed so we're
raising that power at one and then we're
multiplying it by a factor which is
basically the same as the power and then
we need to put in our limits which is
from zero to Big H so final part of an
integrations we have to put these
numbers these limits in here and so
it'll be Big H minus the zero so then it
will be the equals PI big R squared over
big H squared and then it will be the
third big H cubed
- well as zero in here a zero cubes
times 1/3 which it basically just gives
us zero so now we can just get the final
answer so V is equal to we'll take this
1/3 out to the front we've got the
constant from PI we've got the R squared
here and there we have to sort out the
HS so basically this H squared cancels
out with an H grid here and we left up
with just one age so there we go
that's the answer same as what we were
aiming for and it does in fact have a
slightly less weird shaped 3 so that's
how to use calculus to derive the volume
of different shapes you can use the same
procedure for any shape the difficult
steps are actually 1 & 2 first setting
up the sum knowing how to split your
shape into these different bits and then
how to formulate this expression here so
you want to be able to represent all of
the variables in your shape in terms of
the thing that you're minimizing over so
in this case it was height but if you're
doing say sphere what you might do is
take disks concentric disks that get
smaller as you go up
so then what you'll have instead of this
triangular shape when you look side on
what you'll have is actually this line
here so instead of a straight or a
straight line here you'll have to
actually model this curved line here so
you might want to try that on your own
to see if you can apply this yourself
another one which is very similar to
this but slightly different which was
probably a good next step would to be do
a square based pyramid it could also do
a triangular based pyramid too to see if
you can get that I think this is a
really cool example of how you can use
calculus to do something useful and it
kind of unlocked the value of calculus
for me when I first learnt it because
instead of just accepting equations I
could start deriving them for myself I
could see where they came
which was incredibly satisfying I hope
it does the same for you okay but that's
it I hope you've enjoyed this video just
want to tell you I've got some new
posters up on my dftba store map of
chemistry in the map of biology and I've
got a load of other posters there too
alright thanks for watching and I'll see
you on another video very soon
[Music]